pourquoi tu es au meeting d éric démon
pour des raisons très simples je fais
mon boulot de chroniqueurs politiques
bref eric zemmour est un ami je lui ai
dit cent fois que je viens de dire une
101e fois le coq peut chanter trois fois
33 x 333 fois je ne renierai jamais mon
amitié avec eric zemmour et ensuite je
pense que c'était un événement politique
très important hier on connaît enfin le
programme d'eric zemmour c'est un des
principaux prétendants à la
présidentielle donc j'avais toutes les
raisons d'être là donc la polémique me
paraît surréaliste je voulais eric quand
que tu réponds aux gens dont david qui a
et oui tu es qui a dit que tu étais pas
n'était pas dans le avec les régionales
a été au premier rang oui oui mais je
crois que les je crois que l'équipe
d'eric zemmour est au fait de mon amitié
avec le patron ils m'ont procuré une
place vip jeté dans un jeu n'était pas
dans le coin des soutiens les soutiens
ils sont en face de la tribune il se
lève un par un ils prennent la parole
ils disent pourquoi ils soutiennent est
mort et ensuite comme il est de coutume
y chante la marseillaise avec zemmour je
n'ai rien fait de tout ça j'étais dans
mon coin j'avais des j'avais des
photographes à genoux devant moi parce
qu'on était un peu serré dont je ne
faisais pas partie des soutiens et je ne
suis pas un soutien d'eric zemmour je
suis venu en tant qu'ami et en tant que
chroniqueur politique je ne sais ça t'a
plu le meeting pour toi il a réussi son
premier meeting sur la forme il l'a
réussi il a fait des progrès depuis
depuis la convention la droite il a fait
des progrès à l'oral comme tribun qui
sont très très impressionnant après sur
le fond maintenant tout le monde peut se
déterminer par rapport à votre écoute tu
voudras pas pour eric zemmour moi je
suis pour le secret du vote c'est pour
ça que je crois que quand on vote c'est
déjà une petite pièce qui est fermée par
un rideau et je crois que ça corresponde
votre appart aujourd'hui la mélenchon je
ne voterai pas pour jean luc mélenchon
ça tu dis canada à moins qu'il change
beaucoup à moins qu'ils changent
beaucoup d'ici la présidentielle que
j'ai peu d'espoir david toi si tu as ta
pas arrêter toute la journée ça t'a
rendu fou qu'eric naulleau soit au
meeting eric zemmour pas non mais moi ça
en fait ça m'étonne pas mais vous
noterez déjà que ce soir eric naulleau
qui disait hier qu'il y aller en tant
que journaliste maintenant ai dit qu'il
y va en tant que chroniqueur et amis
votre version elle a changé parce que
vous savez très légal réjean moi c'est
la même chose journalistes non
journalistes n'y a pas de journalistes
dans les meetings qui sont au premier
rang vip avec vélo sans rien sans caméra
sur rien juste un grand sourire voilà ça
n'existe pas les journalistes caméra par
ailleurs vous n'êtes pas ami uniquement
d'eric zemmour vous êtes amis des gens
dans la salle parce que vous prenez des
selphy avec eux d'accord donc au bout
d'un moment vous avez tenté de nous
faire croire que vous y était en train
de journalistes c'est pas vrai vous
étiez ça c'est un déguisement votre
déguisement de journalistes là il était
très mauvais aux directives qui se
déguise en petite fille là et il était
très mauvais et maintenant ce qui
convient de dire c'est que vous êtes un
de ses soutiens politiques monsieur vous
êtes pas juste chez un ami attendait un
ami un ami sadinos adin le soir avec son
pote nasa va passer meeting politique
c'est pas vrai nom maintient que tous
les gens qui veulent bien à celle ci
avait vous en fait ce sont vos amis
c'est bizarre on peut on peut faire un
petit tour de table je vous assure on
fait des celle ci avec des génomes et
connaît alors yahia garenne qui veut
réécrire de chardy cela dit les gens
étaient très agréables ensuite monsieur
je vais clore le débat tout de suite je
ne vous reconnais pas le droit de me
dire où je peux m'asseoir et où je ne
peux pas m'asseoir et ça tombe bien je
n'ai pas le droit de nous dire si c'est
au premier rang ou au dernier rang et je
ne vous reconnais pas je crois ni à vous
ni à quiconque de m'expliquer comment je
fais mon métier donc le débat est clos
je m'offre si simple de les battre mais
moi aussi je m'en fous si ça ne vous
plaît pas j'étais dans le carré viiip il
y avait un journaliste mois dans le
carré vieille mais si ça ne vous plait
l'an passé vonau les chemins vous êtes
tout le temps avec lui je veux dire même
des sorties scolaires on voit votre tête
au milieu des gamins en vous est tout le
temps avec eric l'énorme soutien
politique c'est au bout d'un moment fait
vous êtes vous
c'est que la scène à laquelle vous
faites allusion vous êtes aussi scolaire
avec venant du tout 3 on croise une
classe l'accompagnant de la classe
demande à ce que zemmour pose avec les
enfants il insiste voilà moi pour faire
plaisir à ses parents mais oui mais
alors carette non vous n'êtes pas un
crime
parce qu'il suffit d'écouter et eric
naulleau et le lire depuis 10 15 ans
pour savoir qu'il n'est pas d'accord
avec eric zemmour sur le fond
idéologique il le dit depuis 15 ans dix
ans sur l'émission
je le répète ici relisez les tweets de
d'eric naulleau c'est un homme de gauche
un homme de gauche maintenant il ya plus
de gauche de gauche de valenciennes
c'est un homme de la gauche à l'ancienne
qui n'est pas d'accord avec eric zemmour
sur la majorité des points pardon mais
qui a quand même le droit d'avoir une
amitié avec eric zemmour et devenir un
mythe je pense que eric naulleau n'est
pas d'accord avec ce qu'a dit eric
zemmour pendant son pendant sont
dépendants son disco mais il a quand
même le droit de venir sans se faire
insulter par huit l'extrême gauche
samedi en iran personne à part et de
l'insulté c'est jusqu'en février dernier
pourtant faut arrêter de se prétendent
de gauche quand on ne sait jamais quelle
est la mesure d'essayer toujours défendu
vivait sur les no logo vous avez toute
votre carrière était dans la roue de
l'extrême droite vous avez fait des
choses avec avec un art soral qui est
quand même un antisémite soi-disant néo
nazis vous avez animé des émissions avec
eric zemmour tout ça a une raison c'est
parce que sans les fachos vous n'êtes
rien vous avez sorti un livre là en
bulgarie vous avez fait un flop vote
libre il est mauvais et vous êtes en
syrie l'extrême droite oui sur votre
histoire ne vous devriez vous devriez
widi joignez vos fiches parce que la
serbie alors que vous avez vous avez
jamais rien réussi sans l'extrême droite
c'est ça la vérité un ami de votre
parcours pauline jamais rien jamais
arrivé vous juste une question et après
vous fait passer je suis ni juge st vous
fait passer pour quelqu'un de gauche
monsieur on ne sait pas quelles sont les
propositions de gauche que vous êtes
vous essayer de nous faire croire que
vous êtes de gauche n'a joué et fachos
la nuit c'est ça vous êtes comme madame
doubtfire en fait vous changer
d'identité à chaque fois pour être la
caution de gauche d'eric zemmour parce
qu'on sait que vous êtes votre soutien
il y a personne au monde qui ait autant
porter la contradiction à eric zemmour